the Duke and Duchess of Sussex are
definitely feeling the love from all
over the world especially right now in
Australia where they are already showing
off their very natural parenting skills
this little boy named Luke just about
melted the hearts of the Royals with his
cuddly hugs the five-year-old then
affectionately touched Harry's beard and
hair seems the tykes idolizes Santa
Claus and Harry was the next best thing
you couldn't see her little baby bum
because the Duchess wore a loose-fitting
blazer from her friend Serena Williams
fashion line of course the $145 jacket
is sold out and the tennis star posted
this reaction the face you make when you
and Megan have matching Serena Blazers
during a demonstration by paramedics the
couple saw a fake baby in an incubator
they visited an area of Australia that's
been plagued by drought but wouldn't you
know it
they brought rain a beaming Megan even
held an umbrella over Harry as he
addressed the adoring crowd the visiting
country Australia is the people
[Applause]
[Music]